the great thing about the horror genre
is the range of styles that encompasses
everyone's afraid of something and some
of those unique fears have inspired
amazing movies while horror flicks often
come with a sizable body count there's
more to the jar more than just a
well-stocked a list of victims from
ghostly apparitions that haunt families
to the knowledge of someone stalking you
here are the scariest horror movies
where no one actually gets offed on
screen obviously there are a whole bunch
of spoilers ahead poltergeist one of the
most terrifying ghost story movies of
all time poltergeist has been parodied
referenced and even remade but nothing
can detract from the genuinely
frightening visuals and invasive horror
of the film
luckily for the films sent to a family
no one actually gets soft in poltergeist
they're ultimately able to escape of
their lives and TACT's although they
lose a safe sanctuary that their home
represented some would say that's even
scarier than the truly horrific clown
doll the others outwardly a horror movie
about a haunted house the real terror of
the others is in being trapped and
battered by forces you cannot comprehend
as it turns out the family living in
fear of ghosts are themselves the ghosts
well they believe to be the ghosts we're
in fact the new owners of the house it's
a twist of flips horror movie
conventions on their heads showcasing
how horrific a ghost story can be even
for the ghost and since the main family
members were actually ghosts the whole
time and no lives are taken in the movie
itself the babadook like all the best
horror movies the babadook lets the
central monster become symbolic for any
number of horrific real-life experiences
like trauma loneliness and mental
illness the symbolic weight of the film
it doesn't track the film down into
maudlin subtext though you could enjoy
as a simple movie about a single mother
trying to keep her son safe in spite of
its frights the characters make it out
alive in the babadook
although viewers squeamish about
ill-fated family pets should steer clear
14:08 based on one of Stephen King's
short stories
14:08 of a simple hook that's hard to
beat after the loss of his young
daughter a skeptic rents a haunted hotel
room to prove that ghosts don't exist
this is it the horror in the film
doesn't come from Mike's fear of the
ghosts but from his experiences within a
twist of reality Rory can't trust his
senses or even himself despite the rooms
consistent encouragement for him to take
his own life
Mike ends up living through the final
credits one-hour photo Robin Williams is
absolutely chilling as a voyeuristic
stalker in one hour photo the film
follows Williams character as he becomes
obsessed with the family after
developing their photos when he
discovers her family isn't as perfect as
he had believed he begins talking and
even threatening them the movie works on
the horror genre precisely because of
its creepy central character the kind of
person you immediately forget about
after you leave your local store still
despite his creepy behavior this
obsessive stalker doesn't actually take
any lives in the film
signs at one point in time director M
night Shyamalan was the king of the plot
twist and while it might not be the
sixth sense science is a surprisingly
effective horror movie the film follows
a family whose grief at the loss of
their matriarch is interrupted by an
alien invasion the horror is restrained
blending the families questioning faith
with the arrival of alien conquerors so
seamlessly that some fans of theorize
that the aliens are actually demons
whether the monsters are aliens or
demons they're equally ineffective at
taking any lives in the film April force
day the only slasher film on this list
April Fool's Day follows a group of
friends who go on a weekend trip for the
pranks and practical jokes to celebrate
April Fool's Day despite corpses piling
up and lots of blood there are actually
no real victims in the film as it turns
out each supposed victim was actually in
on the joke helping to craft a
specialized horror resorts even a
fake-out finale ends up being nothing
more than a practical joke making this
the bloodiest casualty free movie we can
think of thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]